Good evening everybody and welcome
my name is Trey Grayson
I'm the director of the institute of
politics and i want to welcome everybody
the john f_ kennedy junior forum here at
the harvard kennedy school
uh... before introduce uh... the speaker
Mr. Gingrich I want to go over some ground
rules for tonight's event
uh... freedom of speech and civility
are bedrock principles at the john f_
kennedy junior forum at harvard
university and our democracy
and in fact it is in his inaugural address
president kennedy reminded us
that's civility is not a sign of weakness
and sincerity is always subject to proof
the forum is one of the few places in
america
where you can hear from national and
world leaders
hear them speak
and then have their speeches followed by
an unfettered question-and-answer session
with members of the audience a practice
that invariably results
in lively exchanges
the reason why this is successful is our
audience respects our speakers rights to
free speech
as well as the right
of our audience members to listen to our
speakers
in turn our speakers respect our
audience's right to ask unfiltered
sometimes tough
sorry about that
but always fair
questions
now by following tonight's rules
this is going to be yet another
successful event here at the john f_
kennedy junior forum
so tonight we're pleased to welcome
to the forum speaker mister newt
gingrich, speaker mister speaker i think
is your fourth time here in the forum i
was actually here in
1993 for first address when i
was an undergraduate
and we're glad to have you back
and Mrs. Gingrich it's your first time
glad to have you speaker gingrich
represented
georgia in congress for twenty years
and served as speaker of the united states
house representatives for four years
he is the architect
of contract with america that led the
republican party to victory in
by capturing the majority in the u_s_
house for the first time and forty
years
speaker gingrich received his bachelors
degree from emory university
and a masters in doctorate in modern
european history
from Tulane
university
and before his election to congress he taught
history
and environmental studies at west georgia
college for eight years
Callista the gingrich is the president of
gingrich productions
a multimedia production company based in
washington d_c_
and prior to leaving gingrich
productions
she served eighteen years on staffs in
congress
in the united states house of representatives
she graduated cum laude and earned a
bachelor of arts degree music
with a concentration in public
communication from luther college in
decorah iowa
speaker and missus gingrich host and produce
award-winning documentary films
including a city upon a hill
which e will view today
please join me in welcoming
speaker and missus newt gingrich
good evening and welcome
thank you for coming to our screening of a City upon a Hill
newt and I would like to thank the institute of
politics for the opportunity to be with
you here this evening
we'd also like to thank our producer
david bossi
our director kevin Knoblock
and the entire team at citizens united
productions with whom we made this film
a City upon a hill explores the
concept american exceptionalism
from its origin to present day
puritan john winthrop first captured the
idea of an exceptional nation in 1630
when he encouraged settlers
headed to the new world to create a
community or as he called it
a city upon a hill
to serve as a model for the rest of
the world
our founding fathers had this game idea
in mind when they created america's
founding documents
defined by the ideals of life, liberty
and the pursuit of happiness
at no other time in history
had a nation declared that its citizens
were endowed by their creator
with certain inalienable rights.
rights that no king or government could
take away
this truth
that our rights come from god
has provided americans with boundless freedom
and opportunity
yet today
many misunderstand why america is an
exceptional nation
often claiming that we're no different
from other countries
but american exceptionalism is not a
matter of arrogance
it's a recognition that we are unique
nation
based on individual liberty
dignity
and personal responsibility
if we forget this we will be in danger
of surrendering our rights as
individuals
the antithesis of what our founding
fathers envisioned for america
as citizens we must have the courage to
ensure that america remains an
exceptional nation. a challenge that is the
that essence of the american creed
we hope you'll enjoy a city upon a
hill and share message
thank you and god bless
Let me join Callista in thanking all of you
first of all for being here and for
allowing us to share this with you. I hope
as you watch the film you'll think about
questions
those students are disrupting the forum harvard security
please remove those individuals
so as i was saying I hope that you
will.. Harvard police please make your way
up to there on the third floor sorry mr. speaker
for the interruption
actually I'll be allowed to take questions
later on about those kind of ideas i think
we are 100%
I think we're all americans and I think it's importnant
I started to say I hope as you watch the film
Callista
has written a children's introductory
book for forty to eight olds called Sweet land of Liberty
which actually became a new York Times bestseller
and i wrote book aimed at you and other folks
other citizens called A Nation like No Other
there's a pew result out today that
exactly illustrates why we're having
this conversation
because in order tests how many
americans liked american
exceptionalism
teh pew foundation asked the question
how many of you think our culture is
superior
which is not at all what it means
american exceptionalism relates directly to
one document the declaration of
independence to its assertion
that we hold these truths to be self-evident
that we're all created equal
that we are endowed by our creator
with certain unalienable rights
from that assertion
comes citizenship rather
than being a subject
it's a reason that abraham lincoln
in eighteen sixty one on his way to
being inaugurated
stopped at independence hall
and sat in philadelphia
at the eve of the civil war
nothing that mattered in his political
philosophy in his entire life
came from anywhere except the
declaration of independence
and i believe that next year this will be one
of the central questions in the
presidential campaign
whether we are in fact an exceptional
nation endowed by our creator
or whether like the european countries
we're simply subjects to a government
randomly gathered protoplasm with no
inherent liberties simply existing at
the suffrance of the elites
and i think the difference in those two
is extraordinary i hope you enjoy the
film i look forward to your questions afterwards
i've never been here before that it didn't
turn out to be fun and interesting and different
i'm confident you will make it the same
tonight thank you very much
alright well i think we're ready to have a little
discussion now
we at the uh, at the IOP over the years, we
regularly extend invitations to the major presidential
candidates
and a lot fo them come to speak here at the forum,
we are really glad to have you here. When I emailed you
uh... you said hey I've got an idea
let's do a screening of a documentary
let's talk about
Americna exceptionalism
and then we'll talk and do some q and a
that's not the normal way the candidates respond to
our invitation. We said sure let's do it
and you actually told me, go on the
website pick out one, I hope you all like this one
I picked this out
why
why did you want to do it this way? Why'd you want to show
the documentary and then talk about it?
i think that the
largest choice facing the united states
is actually a cultural choice
and
i began getting involved in this back in
two thousand two
when the ninth circuit court ruled that
one nation under god
in the statue and and and uh... in the
uh... pledge of allegiance
was unconstitutional
interestingly tomorrow
is the anniversary
of lincoln's gettysburg address
and in eighteen sixty three
lincoln sits on the dias,looking out on
the first national military cemetery
the graves of thousands of young men
and he ads to
his address
under God
those you think i was just a random
notation
go to the
lincoln memorial
where on one side you will see
one nation under god
on the other side you'll see
his second inaugural
march of eighteen sixty five
four years of war
six hundred and twenty thousand dead
americans
lincoln
took the war as a personal responsiblity
he knew that
at any point
when he would accept the south leaving
more war would end
so in a sense he willed
the preservation of the union
at the cost of six hundred and twenty thousand dead
it fundamentally reshaped him as a person
you see this if you read his magnificent
rational lawyer-like speech at
cooper union seventy two hundred words
in february of eighteen sixty and then
read
eighteen sixty five
in seven hundred into words
abraham lincoln refers to God fourteen
times
and quotes the Bible twice
now i responded to the ninth circuit
much like lincoln responded to the dred
scott decision in the eighteen fifties which
said that slavery was automatically
extended across the whole country
because I honestly believe that we are
either an exceptional nation endowed by
our creator
with certain inalienable rights in which
case
each one of you is personally sovereign
and youloan power to the state
the state does not loan power to you
i believe this was the heart of america
i think the founding fathers wrote it
very deliberately
it represented the essence of their
understanding of life
that's why they start out by saying we
hold these truths to be self-evident
and i believe it was a great cultural
struggle which this campus is one fo the centerpieces
between people who believe that that's
all nonesense that we're essentially randomly
gathered protoplasm who happened to of
lucked out
and to have ended up geographically in places with
reasonably good government that has not
yet been totally destroyed by power
hungry politicians
but that there's no inherent underlying
structure of exceptionalism
and this notion of exceptionalism is at the very core
of being American
it's why the wright brothers, the
wright brothers the smithsonian are engaged
in a competition
The Smithsonian got just under fifty thousand dollars from
congress and failed
The Wright brothers got nothing and invented
the airplane
and its not the congress, Im not saying the policy
that it's good government or bad government I'm
just saying
the spirit of
entrepreneurial
pioneering the spirit of creating things
this spirit that anyone of us in this
room
can be virtually anything
is a peculiarly american experience
Arnold Schwarzenegger gets to be governor of our
largest state
worth hundreds of millions of dollars
if he ha dstayed in austria
he would have been hopeless
nobody of his background could've become
president of Austria
would've been an absurdity
yet here he can
and so we engage in a cultural struggle plus
i've now done seven movies all of them
documentaries as part of the cultural
struggle
i've written a series of books, she's just written
Sweet Land of Liberty for 4-8 year olds
but this is the cultural component of the
political campaign
I'll give you one example
i have a proposal
that if you get unemployment
compensation
you should be required to sign up for
a training program
we should not give people money for
ninety nine weeks for doing nothing
that it fundamentally undermines them
limits them
weakens them
and if you can't find a job
we ought to take the time we are paying
you
and make sure you learn so you can
actually get a job
because that way you dramatically expand
human capital but you also reestablish the
work ethic
obviously all of you are students and
you're all elite students at an elite university
so this will not shock you
but one of my messages is a, this is a sign of
how daring I am as a candidate
as I go around the country I say look, one of the
keys is really simple
students are going to actually have to study
you know we actually have to have grades given
based on achievement
we can't afford a socially promote
because it cheats the kids
now that's the skill of difference
uh... that i think we represent and in
this film in essence, I've always thought
there would be three great themes next year
if i end up uh...
in seven
three-hour debates with the president Obama
one would be the economy, I mean how could have this level of
disaster and not have that focus
that focus
the second would be the question of
american exceptionalism vs
the sort of bureaucratic socialist model
and the third would be national
security
and that those three will be the
organizing principles in the entire campaign
and that's why this film i thought
was a very useful starting point. All right well let's
go to those other two topics for the debates
uh... let's start with the economy what would you
do if you were president to get this economy
moving again
One of the reasons I became a historian
is that imitation is cheaper than invention
so you want to solve something
go look for somebody that solved it
i've been through two sets of solutions
on the economy nineteen seventy nine
nineteen eighty
art laffer who's up there who invented
the laffer curve
uh... jude wanniski jack kemp uh...
bunch of us helped create supply-side
economics ronald reagan campaigned on it
i campaigned with him i was a freshman
congressman
reagan had four pillars to his
economic policy
cut taxes cut regulations developme
American energy
and reward, honor, and
talk well of people who create
jobs
the opposite of obama's which is higher
taxes
more regulation anti-american energy
and class warfare
what was the result? and just objective
facts this goes back to the phrase empiricist
uh... that was used at one point
in september of nineteen eighty three
we created a million one hundred
thousand jobs in one month
under reagan job creational minimum was such
uh...
that given our current population base
it would be twenty five million new jobs
so
we slid back a little bit
there was a tax increase i thought we were
in a recession
i get elected speaker
and what do i do?
cut taxes cut regulations focused
on American energy
support people who create jobs what was the
result?
in the four years i'm speaker we create
eleven million new jobs
unemployment drops to 4.2
percent
now what's the fiscal consequence for
everybody's watching this idiotic supercommittee?
fiscal consequence is simple
when i went into office the congressional
budget office said in the next ten years
the deficit would be
two point seven trillion dollars
when i left office after four years the
congressional budget office said
the surplus
would be two point three trillion
dollars
that's a five trillion dollars swing
ironically nobody that i know of at the
budget committee
on the super committee
has reached out to anybody who's
actually balanced the budget
and I'm the only speaker
in your life time to balance a budget for four
years
uh... why did it happen like that?
well if you if you create jobs
you take people off of  medicaid off of
public housing
off of food stamps off of unemployment
off of welfare so you're reducing government
spending
without paying you know you're not going
out here chopping people off
they're leaving to go to work
when they go to work they're paying
taxes so you actually have a reduction
in cost
a rise in unfor hire revenue, just again taxes
you have a rise in revenue
and the consequence of those is the
largest single step you ever take to a
balanced budget
so the third pillar or the third topic of conversation
you wanted to have with president Obama if you were the nominee
was involving national security how would you keep
our country safe what do you see as our role in the
world
well i think first of all
this would be moderate controversial
we were in the world
there's no conceivable
isolationism
that will work
that's very important because once you start
out be saying we're in the world then you say okay,
so if we if we are an exceptional unique
civilization
how do we defend our interest in the
world how to express our values in the
world
and that becomes a very large and very
complex question
i'll just take two examples
let's take China and
radical islam's
both of which require fundamental thought
the president just engaged in
symbolic
behavior in australia
we're going to send twenty five hundred marines
to Australia
now that's irritating the chinese
but i doubt if it's impressiing them
they have the largest army in the
world they have, you know, and the idea oftwenty five hundred
marines
i'm an army brat I express a certain bias
thos eof you who are marines semper fi
I'm just telling you, twenty five hundred
marines aint enough
and yet it is actually a useful thing to
do
i'm not against doing it
but it's not central to our relation
with China. if you really want to
worry about china
ironically you have to worry about the
united states what are the key factors
rebuild our industrial base
rebuild our science and technology base
rebuild our education system if we get
america straight, the chinese won't catch up
with us in a hundred years
if we don't get america straight the
chinese are gonna pass us 'cause we're stupid
now it is not possible
for us to make an argument with the chinese
that they owe it to us to be as dumb as
we are
and so if we really want to compete
with china
we have got to focus and and this came
straight out of a art redman
commission
which i helped create with president
clinton and when i stepped down he asked me
to serve on it
uh... we spent three years studying
american national security reported in
march of two thousand one we said the
greatest threat united states was a
weapon of mass destruction
went off in an american city probably by a
terrorist group we said the second greatest
threat to the united states
is the failure of math and science
education
and the failure to invest in science and
technology
and we then said what i thought was a
startling thing for a national security
uh... report we said
it is a greater
threat than any conceivable conventional
war
so i would argue that fixing the schools
fixing the industrial base
rebuilding our investment in science and
technology are national security issues
and if we do them right the chinese are
sort of irrelevant we don't do them
right
frankly we're in enormous trouble
the middle east is totally different i was very sobered
a couple months ago
general john abizaid who i believe is the
only four star general who is fluent in arabic
was the head of the central command now retired
but he's been saying
our strategic deficit is greater than
our fiscal deficit
and that's a very sobering way to think
about it. we are in a
challenge in the middle east
so much larger and more complex
than anything our current foreign-policy
establishment can deal with
that is very very
sobering
and i think we need to talk about it and in
that sense i don't think that i don't
know that i'm a hawk
so much as i am an owl I think we need wisdom
in trying to deal with this because it
is a very very serious problem
before we open up to the audience, I'm going to
ask you a couple personal questions
our mission at the IOP is to inspire students to pursue
careers in politics and public service
why'd you decide to run for office the first time?
I was
originally going to be either a zoo director
uh... or a
and i know what some of you are thinking
it came in handy when you were speaker. well that is a
great book there's a great book by uh...
uh... called a chimpanzee politics
which i recommend to all of you which is a study of the
social structure of the arnhem zoo's
chimpanzees colony
but it's a really great introduction to politics
among large primates
uh...
and it's a terrific book
uh... but anyhow I was going to be either a
zoo director or a vertibraepaleontologist
and uh...
in the uh...
my dad was stationed in orleansfrance he was in
the infantry for twenty seven years
and we
late in my freshman year in high school
we went to the battlefield Verdun
which was the largest battlefield of
world war one about six hundred thousand
french and german dead in a nine month period
and um...
stayed with a friend of my fathers who had
uh... been drafted in nineteen forty one
sent to the philippines served in the
bataan death march
and ended up spending three and half years
in a japanese prison camp
so
we were talking all weekend about the
cost of defeat
and then
literally the french paratroopers came
in from algeria killed french fourth
republic
and brought de gaulle back to create the fifth
and shortly after that we moved to
stukgard
so as a young kid from Harrisburg
pennsylvania I'm thinking
this is all real. we used to
drive our bus to the
american school
passed world war two bomb damage so
all of this was extraordinary real
and i spent the summer thinking and
praying about it and in august of
1958 just before my sophmore year in
high school
uh... i decided that
my mission if you will
uh... or my vocation
uh... was too
do three things understand what american
has to do to survive
understand how to explain it to the
american people that let you do it
and understand how you would implement it
if they give me a shot
so i from that point on have read books
in the summer of nineteen sixty i was a
volunteer
in the Nixon-lodge campaign
went back to reading books
and i went back and forth that way for my
whole career
and so i've been actively this is my
fifty third year
of trying to understand what we have to do
as a country
well my last question is one a student asked me to
ask you we're in a
part of harvard named after president
kennedy
who was the first catholic president of the United States and
the only catholic president to date
uh... but a few years ago you converted to
catholicism what motivated that and how
is that
shift that in your uh... your faith
your uh...
impacted your political beliefs
if at all
i think what happened was
my wife Callista who all of you met earlier
is a cradle catholic and sings in the
choir
of the uh
basilica of the national shroud of the
immaculate conception the largest catholic church
in the United States
and so just to be supportive
I used to go every Sunday and watch
being a good husband. right and uh...
plus given my musical skills I thought my
sitting in the audience was a terrific ...good spot for you
yeah yet
uh... but i found myself over time
i think part of my soul is medieval
and so i found myself over time that the
basilica is an extraordinary
institution and
i became more and more and more
comfortable and frankly more and more
intrigued
with the Catholic approach
to the eucarist
and i got involved in long conversation
with monsignor Rossi who was the
director of the basilica
and it just struck me that
the combination of the intellectual background
of
two thousand years of catholic
scholarship
and the power of
the representation of christ every sunday
or everytime you go to mass seven days a week
if you go seven days a week
is an extraordinary
experience
when uh...
Pope Benedict came and i got to know much deeper because
the choir went to Rome
and i went along it was one of the first
times in my life I actually took a week
off i was the spouse
uh... and when they were making a cd
recording a cd for
pope john paul the second
and so i had spent the afternoon and
evening relaxed
and then they'd come back about eleven
o'clock and they'd decided to do all the recording
in the evening when the church was that
they were in, the Santa Maria majority was
closed to tourists
and so Monseignor Rossi and i would talk and
then when they came back about eleven o'clock
at night we'd go to some fabulous local
italian restaurant in Rome
and my job was essentially to provide
the wine
uh... and and so i was very popular with the choir
and uh... i but the course of those
conversations started the process of
thinking and talking about
the role, the centrality of religion
uh... and when pope benedict came I was allowed as a
speaker of the House to be at the basilica
when the bishops met with the pope
and i happened to see him
and there was something about the sense
of joy and and the fact
uh...
that he had chosen christ our hope which
i happen to believe is true, we're going all the way back to
when my grandmother was raising me as a child my
grandmother
when my mother was working my
grandmother sort of took over
and was very intensely focused on
convincing me
that there is heaven and that there is hell
that there's an extreme difference the two
futures
and that she was prepared to communicate
hell as vividly as needed for me to decide
that heaven is a better choice
and just
so i tell people I didn't decide to
become Catholic, I gradually became
catholic
and woke up to that realization
the biggest thing it's done for me is it
is a sense of being at peace with myself
and that is really uh...
the church is an extraordinary
community within which to seek
reconciliation with God
well we're gunns, now we're gunna invite the audience to
participate, we've got four microphones there's two on the
floor
there's two in the booth. we'll try to get
through as many questions as we can
just a couple reminders of our standard rules
here at j_f_k_ junior forum uh... please
identify yourself and your harvard
affiliation
uh... one
brief question per questioner no speeches
uh... we had one
well ti wasn't really a speech but it's his show it's not your show
uh... and the best questions are those that end
with a question mark. and we  will
start right here
Hi my name is Denise Velasco and I'm a student here at the
Kennedy School I'm a Mid-career PA candidate
okay
it was mentioned in the movie that
american exceptionalism in part
is the idea that it doesn't matter if
you're rich or poor and it doesn't
matter who your parents are
it's a sharp turn from immigration
legislation that you strongly supported
in nineteen ninety-six that would bar the
children of undocumented immigrants
from schools
how do you reconcile
that contradictory idea that still pursists in your
party
well i think we have a long tradition of
being the most open to immigration of
any country in the world
I think we have an extrodinary challenge, if you live
in a world of 7 billion people
for whom probably uh... the number who would come here
tomorrow morning if
they could find a way to get here would
at least double population
uh... so you have a permentation
I think the correct answer
is to
control the border
and to find a way to have a guest worker program
that is effective
and to find some kind of process
i've suggested a world war two style
selective service model
uh... which would allow you to to sort
out people who have only been here a
short time and have no real ties
who ought to go home
and people been here a long time and have real ties and
the Creeble foundation has
suggested what it would be calling a red card
program
uh... as a way of uh... giving people a path to legality
without having a path to citizenship
and i'd like to see us get to a point
where
everybody who remains in the u_s_ is
legal
uh... and has access to all of the
assets of the united states
but I think it's a process..even the children of undocumented
immigrants?
if if they are here and go through this process and they
end up with a
red card yes
If they don't end up with a red card and they don't end up with a
guest worker
permit
then i would not allow them to stay here
uh... which is why i think you've got to render judgment
]i don't think we're gonna take
someone who's been here twenty three
years you know, has three kids
and two grandkids and belongs to a local church
and has been totally law-abiding since
they got here i do not believe we're
gonna kick them out
and I think we've gotta have an honest conversation about
immigration reform
not just each side yelling at eachother
thank you. next question right here
uh...
first of all thank you very much for
coming here and speaking to us and for this
interesting movie
uh
My name is bernard Metz I am an MPA
a student at the kennedy school from
europe
and i have a question on what do you
think about europe
which part of Europe are you from?
uh... Bavaria
so the uh... movie and the definition
of exceptionalism.. I like beer
everybody likes beer, ybut they don't like American
beer that much
well actually I like guiness more because
I'm half Irish
I actually like czech beer but that's a different story
Pilsner urquel or? pilsner ukved
so the movie base the
definition on of exceptionalism to
a high degree
uh...on differentiation from
what was mentioned several times
corrupt
unfree
europe and other parts of the world
which was certainly true two hundred and
fifty years ago and i totally agree
uh... that's
that there were good reasons for coming
to
the free united states
but uh...
then afterwards now you also mentioned
that you think that arnold Schwarzenegger
couldn't have become
president of austria
so um...
i'm wondering
do you base your
perception of europe on historical facts
or do you still think that europe is a
dictatorship and if so.. i didn't say there was a
dictatoship, essentially there is a
class system
that is very hard to break through
it's still true even in great britain, there are
extraordinary differences of class
and and uh...
who gets to rise and who doesn't the
political party systems are dramatically
more closed there than they are here
look look at our wild and wide open
political presidential races
whether it's last time when the heir
apparent got defeated by Obama
or is this time we can't figure out who
the front runner is because they don't last long enough
uh... this is the most open to
talent system on the planet
that's just an objective fact
but I was describing
cultural and cast and societal behaviors
it had nothing to do with dictatorship
uh... it has to do with the fact that
europe tends to be run by oligarchies
who love cartels and who try to avoid the public
by burying everything in bureaucracy just
look at, I did my dissertation
in brussels
just got to look at the uh... the common
market bureaucracy in brussels and the
degree to which it represents a
bureaucratic control of europe
uh... hidden away from the average
person
there is dramatically less democracy in europe
than there's united states
there twenty five thousand bureaucrats
in brussels running a system of five
hundred million people
uh... average
city in the united states has more bureaucrats
but ok, that's not a question so i'm done
Hi Speaker i'm Holly Flynn i'm a freshman at the college
and two details from your film really stood out to
me one was phyllis schlafly's
commentary
and the other was the characterization
of women winning world war two
as a negative image
so i'd like you to clarify your stance on women's
rights
and i'd like to hear what you would do
to ensure
gender equality
in the united states given that
even today women make seventy seven
cents to every man's dollar
well
the later is going to change dramatically in the next
generation because more women are going to
college than men
and they're doing better than men and they're entering
professions more than men
and in fact if anything you'll be here
in fifteen years
wondering what we do about male inequality and male
unemployment
because the people who've had the deepest
decline
in income in fact are males who don't go to
college
uh... but that will be another story another day
um
on schlafly's case the only thing that i thought schlafly
really talked about was that
if you redistribute wealth you took money
from somebody
and you have to ask the moral question
by what right are you taking money
why does this group on this side of the room
have the right to take money from this
group on this side of the room i thought that was
all that schlafly talked about
uh... so i'm not quite, I understand you
may have other arguments with schlafly
uh but it struck me that was the only thing
and i think the point he is making about Rosie the riveter
was not that rose the riveter
wasn't important
uh... i suspect he would have said
had the same school taught about the
women's army air corps
had they taught about women's roles in
ferrying aircraft
etc, he would have found it much more appealing
but he was trying to make a point about
the way we approach world war two
world war two was probably as
elegantly fought and as heroic a war as
we've ever had
and involved an enormous amount of sacrifice
uh... and that is not the model that is
normally taught the example again
uh... is is trying to discuss ever Heroshima and
Nagasaki
without discussing pearl harbor
or without discussing what the estimates
were of casualties
if in fact we had not used the atomic
bomb
I mean it's pretty to say well boy, that's really terrible
to use the atomic bomb
it's pretty hard to say okay you're Harry Truman
you're being told five million japanese
and a million americans will be killed
now you've two choices which to do
as uh
charlton heston was one of the
eighteen-year-old paratroopers in
training to go into japan
he said he was eternally grateful
because he frankly didn't think he'd live
if you looked at iwo jima and you looked at
okinawa and you looked at the casulty rate
and you projected and said what was this going to be
like
now i think what that particular author is talking about
is that there si a consistent biased
against
american heroism american decency
in the modern academic elites
and on the floor
thank you, my name is daniel fin i'm s midcareer
MPA student here at harvard kennedy
school for government
for speaker for american exceptionalism mr speaker,
in nineteen ninety eight
under your speakership
the congress passed
a uh... the foreign affairs reform and the
restructuring act
which among other things
abolished the US infomation agency
no this has received uh... critisisms
uh... along the way
the typical example is so four years
ago
republican potential candidate
john mccain
made it his
campaign pledge
to reestablishing the information agency
now my question to you
is uh...
in hindsight do you think uh... it was a
mistake to abolish the agency in
nineteen ninety eight
and uh... would you seek if you uh...
if you are the president, seek to re-establish
this agency or something to that effect
to revitalize american public diplomacy
uh... why and why not
great question i think it was a mistake
uh... i think we greatly underestimated
how much it would be in effect
destroyed
by the state department beaurocracy
i strongly favor reestablishing a u_s_
information agency having it under an
independent board and reverting to the model we used
so effectively in the cold war
thank you mr speaker my name's christopher lloyd i'm a second
year student at the harvard business school
in your movie you talked about the importance virtue to the
idea of american exceptionalism and i was wondering if you
could talk about some the ethical principles that drive your
decision making and also given some your public
ethical lapses
how can america be sure that you'd be a virtuous president?
uh... well i think first of all that as a general rule what
the founding fathers meant by virtue
was in fact their behavior in public
life
and their committment to the country and their dedication
to the country
and i think that in that sense
as i said earlier i've spent fifty three
years trying to understand how to help save this
country i've had a very long and
consistent career in terms of advocating
a whole set of values that involves
smaller government lower taxes balanced
budgets
and strong american nationalism
and i think you can look at my record
overall
and then you have to decide for yourself
but i think in terms of being
both consistent and willing to absorb
a pretty substantial beating from the
elite media
i'm probably
uh... as willing to sacrifice for this country's future
uh... as anybody you've seen in public
life in your lifetime and i do it
because i think in the tradition of my
stepfather
who as i said earlier was a career
infantryman for twenty seven years
some citizens have to be enagaged directly
uh... in trying to stand up for the
country
speaker gingrich
thank you for your service and for your
time
my name is luke scanlan i'm a mid-career
uh... m_p_a_ here at the kennedy school uh...
and so i'm one of the
conservative students here in the body
and uh... we have a great time finding
a lot of conversation with all of
our colleagues uh... as i recently told
someone we've learned how to get along
despite our differences
and understand better why that we don't
disagree
one of the things that many of us are
concerned about is corporate donations
to campaigns and a fear
that campaigns particularly politics can be
bought and no longer really truly
accessible
to everybody
so as a president what are you going
to do about making sure that when we
have donations that that does not
override the political process
and something else along those lines is
how much time are people actually
spending
the people we elect, how much time are they
spending understanding politics verses
out raising money for the next campaign
it's a great, those are both great questions
they're very important questions
and they
i want to deal with them separately as they are so
important
i think the entire
post-watergate
micro-beaurocratization of politics has
been a disaster
when you set a twenty five hundred
dollar cap on what people can give
what you actually do
is guarantee incumbents spend all their
time raising money
and their goal is to create a mountain
so high that no challenger can match it
because the challenger has to go out and try to raise twenty
five hundred units
and they can't do it
uh... well some of you say well there's too much money
spent in politics and i'll just say to you
this is a very expensive country
look at the amount of money we spend for cat food
look at the amount of money spent for deodorant
this is a very expensive country
you're trying to deal with a government
that is a four trillion dollar government
you're going to have a lot of money
spent in some form
i think we'd be vastly better off
to have a very simple law that says anyone
can give any amount of after-tax income
as long as it is reported every night on
the internet
and you would overnight reduce the
amount of time people spend raising
money
and you'd have people be able to say hey look you don't want
to donate to me that's fine
i'm going to go over here, my experience was i've
never had to change a position
in order to raise money
i had to find the people who agreed with
my position
and if i found people who agreed with my position
i could raise a fair amount of money
uh... the second half of what he said
though i think is really a disaster at two
different levels
what's happened is we've grown a
consulting industry
so that instead of having the old-time
big-city machine bosses you now have
these consultants
and these consultants earn a living and
sometimes an extraordinarily good living
out of selling, out of buying advertising and
getting a percent of what they buy
and so the consultants are very heavily
in favor of advertising and they're very
heavily in favor of very simple-minded
candidates whose primary job is to raise
money so the ideal consult model is
you go out and raise money
in order to hire me i will then write
talking points for you to get through
the news program and i will then take
the money you have to write really
vicious thirty second ads and push pull
polls and other things
so you'll win the election
and then you will arrive in washington
knowing nothing
but when you get to washington you can
hire a chief of staff
who will then write talking points for
you while you go to the
you know, this isn't we back and study people like abe
lincoln
or jefferson or washington
or even up as late as FDR and and
and in a unique way ronald reagan who was
totally an anomaly and outside the
normal system
lincoln personally spends three months
researching
his speech at cooper union
he personally writes it
he understands what is argument, he
knows what he is saying
and i mean people talk about the
these debates recently
you know the truth is i prepare for
debates seven days a week
fifty two weeks a year
and then sometimes a debate shows up
but i don't go rushing around and say to
my team why don't you tell me the seven
things i should memorize for this evening
uh... i find and i just think that's
apalling because
the person you elect has to go and
actually make real decisions
and so i think i think this whole current
model has got to be fundamentally rethought
for off speaker gingrich i would just like to thank
you for your time
uh... my name is sarah i'm a freshman at the
college
and my question is
uh... a recent study by researchers at
harvard business school and duke
university found profound economic
inequality in the united states
though wealth, twenty percent americans
hold eighty five percent of the wealth
while the poorest forty percent hold less
than one percent
and the oecd recently found
that social mobility across generations in the united
states is among the lowest in the developed world
if a core american value is that all
men and women are created equal are
we upholding that value if for children born
into such profound inequality and if not
how can we as a nation do better
that's a good
that's a very good question and i would say to
you that uh...
the report you just read represents three
different parallel
policies of government failure
the third and most recent is
the collapse of housing values
since the middle class build a large
part of its wealth around its homes
when you have an across the board
collapse in housing value
you just devalue a large part of the
savings of middle class
and you guarantee an increase in the
inequality
because of the scale of loss they have
because they disproportionately
have their wealth captured in their homes
uh... second
the collapse of manufacturing and having had
a government policy which has been
explicitly anti manufacturing
means that people who are at the margins who
historically
would've worked their way up and rick santorum
is actually totally right on this
uh... the people who would have worked themselves
up through manufacturing jobs
don't have jobs
and so you cut off the way in which
they would have risen so that they might
well have a pretty good job working in a
blue collar factory while their child got a
pretty good job running the blue collar
factory and their grandchild had a
pretty good job owning the blue collar
factory
today that first rung is gone
third and this is something that no liberal
wants to deal with
core policies of protecting unionization
and bureaucratization against children
in the poorest neighborhoods crippling
them
by putting them in schools that fail has
done more to create income inequality
in the united states
than any other single policy
it is tragic
what we do in the poorest neighborhoods
in trapping children
first fo all in child laws which are truly
stupid
okay you say somebody you shouldn't go to
work before you're what fourteen sixteen
years of age? fine
you're totally poor
you are in a school that is failing with
a teacher that's failing
i tried for years to have a very simple
model
most of these schools ought to get rid of the
unionized janitors have one master
janitor and pay local students to take
care of the school
the kids would actually do work
they would have cash
they'd have pride in the schools
they'd begin the process of rising. you go
out and talk to as i do regularly talk to
people who are really successful in one
generation
they all started their first job
between nine and fourteen years of age
they all were either selling newspapers
going door-to-door
they were doing something they're washing
cars
they all learned how to make money at a
very early age what do we say the poor kids
in poor neighborhoods
don't do it. i mean remember all the stuff about don't
get a hamburger-flipping job
the worst possible advice to give to poor
children
get any job that teaches you to show up on
monday
get any job that teaches you to stay all day even if you
have a fight with your girlfriend
i mean the whole process of
get making work worthwhile essential
we have cut, and this is a huge, you put
your finger on it i take seriously
that every american of every ethnic
background in every neighborhood
has the right to pursue happiness
and that it was endowed by their creator
that means you're going to see from me
extraordinarily radical proposals
to fundamentally change the culture of
poverty in america and to give people a
chance to rise very rapidly
one last example jack kemp and i worked
in the eighties
on a concept where people in public
housing
could acquire sweat equity by taking
care of the public housing
they could only overtime own the public
housing
we were deeply attacked by liberals in
the congress
who said do you realize in new york city
if you allow poor people to acquire
ownership of their condominiums
they could sell them for over a million
dollars
and they wouldn't be poor anymore
and we said yes do you realize what you
just said
and the people most opposed to it were the
housing unions
who do not want to see the housing authority
replaced
by poor people rising into the middle class
status
i just shared those ideas
we probably only have time for two more questions
so this one and this one and try to keep them brief,
i apologize to the others
mr speaker first thank you so very much
for your service and also thank you for your intellectual
representation of conservatism i greatly
appreciate that on a personal level
and on a level much bigger than myself and just
before getting to my question i want to remind
everybody that
disagreement does not need to
entail disrespect and unfortunately sitting
in the audience having to listen to
snikers and sneers and all of that
upon your video i find that quite
unfortunate that that could occur here
at such a wonderful university. now to get to my
question ok my name is justin smith an i'm
an alum with the extension school so i
actually really did work my way into
harvard you could say
my question is this mr speaker many
characterize uh... a lot of the things that
you have done uh... and as your tenure
as speaker and as a politician
such as having the video afterwards with
nancy pelosi and working with many
democrats is going to be your achilles heel
in this primary but uh...
don't you think you could characterize that
as your one really true advantage that in
this time where things are so polarized as
we've seen with these ninety nine and
one percenters and that and as you said we
are the hundred percent i mean
isn't that your biggest advantage?
well not necessarily my biggest advantage
hahahahahahaha but look i i do think it's an
advanatge and frankly the
palosi ad was a mistake, i've said it was juts a dumb ad
but on the other hand i'm prepared to
debate any
conservative
about the time i spent going around the
country with reverend al sharpton
talking about the importance of charter
schools
going into black neighborhoods where he
had real standing and where people listen
to him
and i would argue that that anyone who
truly wants to govern america
has to be prepared to go into every
neighborhood of every background in the
entire country and i can promise you
that if i'm invited by the
NAACP
i will go and speak to the convention
and if i'm invited
uh... by by lulac or leros or
anybody else i will go and speak to their
convention
we have to become a country
in which we're prepared to speak across
boundaries when we passed welfare reform
it was a hundred and one democrats voting
yes
and a hundred and one democrats voting
no
it is possible to govern in a bipartisan
and remember
nothing i accomplished as speaker
would've become law without bill clinton's signature
so you have, nothing that ronald reagan
would want to accomplish
could get through the u_s_ house without
one-third of the democrats because
o'neill was the speaker
and so we had to peel away a third of
the democrats on every key vote
in order to past things in reagan's first
term so
i've got a long period of experience of doing
things this way and uh... do want to put in
two quick commercials
if you'd like to know more about what
i'm doing go to on first namw it's
newt.org
and i do want to ask all of you to
consider, i'm not going to ask any of you to be for me
because if you're for me you'll go
home and hope that i fix it
i will ask you all to consider being
with me
for the next eight years
because this is going to be a tremendous struggle
and i'll need you with me every day for eight
years
to get this accomplished now you
had the last question
yes my name is resvano rashano i'm with masters
in public policy
i would ask you to comment whetheror not you would
extend the
concept that you presented before as the
american exceptionalism to the situation where
a hundred and eighty countries in the world
pay for example their dues to the united
nations and the united states does not
but also ask you to
say whether in your opinion it is american
exceptionalism
that the treaty against landmines for example
and the kyoto protocol
are two things that
most of the countries of the world have
signed up to
and united states has not so
with the greatest respect i'm going to
ask you yes or no if you become
president of the united states will the
US fall back on its dues
to the united nations
will you sign
the land mine treaty and will you sign the kyoto
protocol thank you
if all you want is a yes or no the answer is no
kyoto protocol is incredibly written
to the advantage of the europeans
and explicitly against our advantage it
couldn't get a single vote in the united
states senate not even
not a single liberal democrat voted for it
because it was so badly written
the land mine convention is a terrific
idea as long as you're not sending
troops anywhere
it's a terrible idea if in fact you're
sending troops anywhere so there are a
lot of the reasons why the united states is
very cautious about these things
uh... third
i'm happy to consider paying dues
to the united nations, remember the current failure
unesco for us to pay our dues is a
direct function of the fact
that they have recognized the palestinian
authority in absolute violation of the
oslo accords and in away which is a
fundamental violation of united states
position on uh...
uh... the problems in the middle east
but i will also tell you i was co-chair
of the united nations reform uh...
commission with uh... senator george
mitchell
and united nations was one of those perfect examples
of a place
that has an image that has no
relationship to its reality
uh... so i'm happy to represent american
exceptionalism and i suspect as
president i would nominate somebody to
be
uh... the un the un ambassador
who would be very aggressive and
demanding reform un and
very aggressive in fighting against
ideas that are antithetical to the
values and the interest of the united states i
have no interest
in in any way abrogating america's
interest
on behalf of some vague concept of
internationalism
uh... that in fact i think has no context
in in the real world
i want to thank you thank mrs gingrich
for a
very educational and entertaining evening. i want to thank
the audience for being so good please join me in thanking them